today on the matt walsh show as mask
mandates return and talk of lockdowns
picks up
it's clear that no amount of coveted
risk is acceptable with that in mind i
have come up with a three-phase plan to
eliminate
the coveted risk and ensure that all of
us can live safely
and happily forever and i will share
that with you today also we have our
five headlines including the journalists
who had her own proposal to make porn
for kids
yes really plus facebook gets ready to
unveil glasses that will record
everything we do
sounds fantastic and a restaurant owner
calls chris cuomo to task live on air
we'll play the heartwarming clip for you
in our daily cancellation we'll deal
with chris hayes from
msnbc who made an argument for masking
while vaccinated
that is truly breathtaking in its
stupidity and we'll talk about that much
more today on the matte wall show
[Music]
this weekend washington dc will become
the latest locality
to reinstate mass mandates for everyone
in the city regardless of vaccination
status
this move has been prompted by a rash of
covet deaths in the city and by rash of
deaths i mean
uh two a total of two people have died
of the virus
in dc in the past two weeks deaths and
hospitalizations are down across the
country which is probably why
we're hearing a lot uh we're hearing so
much now about cases but not so much
about the people with those cases and
how they're actually faring
we hear about the cases but then the
question of okay well how are those
people doing
the answer is almost all of them are
doing okay
many have no symptoms at all or only
mild symptoms and yet even though
vaccinated people are almost certainly
not going to develop any serious
complications from the virus if they
somehow contract it
the mortality rate for the vaccinated is
a fraction of a percent and even though
many millions of people have
natural immunity from prior infection
and even though a large portion of the
unvaccinated
non-immune are young people and children
who have never been
under any serious threat from the virus
and even though deaths have dropped
precipitously and have not risen
precipitously
even as cases rise americans all across
the country are being told by the cdc to
begin wearing masks again
um there's talk of a return to lockdowns
in some parts of the country or perhaps
everywhere
in a press briefing yesterday the white
house was asked about this
are we gonna go back to lockdowns and uh
they certainly would not rule it out
let's listen to that
president says we are not returning to
lockdowns
shutdowns and school closures but he
also once said that we didn't have to
wear masks anymore once we were
vaccinated so why should
americans trust him now well because we
listen to the scientists
we listen to the expert this is a public
health situation this is not about
politics at all this is about saving
lives
and this is what the president is all
about he wants to make sure that we are
saving lives
if you look at peter the last six months
that's what he's done
every day and we and you see that in the
numbers now we're at a point
where we have to double down and make it
very very clear to people
that we can't we can't let the pandemic
win we have to continue to
fight so if you're listening to the
science if scientists come to you
at some point down the line and say it
is our opinion that there should be
shutdowns and there should be school
closures
you would do that well we listened to
like i said we listened to the cdc
and the the expert and the and their
guidance
are you know are the cdc is a is a body
that is very well respected
and uh we found again we follow their
guidance
very well respected by who exactly
themselves
but hey this is about saving lives
double down so that the pandemic doesn't
win
and the media has gone into full panic
mode which isn't to suggest that it ever
left full panic mode
last night the term ebola was trending
on social media because of
a washington post article warning that
the delta variant is more contagious
than ebola
now that's no doubt true but then
lots of things are more contagious than
ebola ebola is in fact
very difficult to spread as it requires
you to have direct contact
with somebody's bodily fluids
you may as well say that the delta
variant is more transmissible than
cancer i mean that would also be true
technically but rather misleading
meanwhile don lemon on cnn ranted wildly
about all of the rights that must be
immediately revoked from the
unvaccinated
you have to have leaders start speaking
the truth you have to have leaders
the data will be more yeah of course i
said that is true but also
i mean in addition to you've got to have
people start speaking the truth you
can't have them speaking out of both
sides of their mouth saying
yeah well i trust the science and i'm
doing this i heard you had jerome adams
on and he's saying
talking about some right-wing uh
conservative uh
propaganda hosts who are saying oh yeah
no one really said get vaccine they said
i believe in the science
and it's up to you to get it we can't
have mealy-mouthed people like that
you have to be more direct
it's a more concerted effort to say get
vaccinated
because you're not just killing yourself
you're going to kill other people
that's what you have to start telling
people you got to start telling people
if you don't get vaccinated
you can't come into this office or this
place of business if you don't get
vaccinated you can't come to work
if you don't get vaccinated you can't
come into this gym
if you don't get vaccinated you can't
come into this get onto this airplane
it it has nothing to do with freedom
there's nothing new with liberty you
don't have the freedom and the liberty
to put other people in jeopardy you
don't have the freedom
to put other people in jeopardy that's
interesting uh and that may seem extreme
what he just said there but it pales in
comparison to other proposals that have
been
put forward ian millhiser a reporter for
vox urged congress to raise the
tax rates on the unvaccinated to 99
percent
in fairness he probably thinks the tax
rate on everybody else should be like 95
but 99 and i suppose this would at least
save them from the indignity of being
kicked out of restaurants and planes
like don lemon wants as they won't have
enough money to do any of that in the
first place
all in all it's clear that no amount of
coveted risk is tolerable
daily death rates are down so low that
in many major american cities
they can be counted on one hand and yet
that is still too much to bear
100 000 people can die of the flu in a
given year that's
100 000 people that's 33 911s or 66
titanics or 625
oklahoma city bombings and nothing will
be done about it
no measures taken no public health
policies put in place
at all no masks no panic
no it's not just that with with flu
there's less
of that it's that there's none
in fact we don't even talk about it you
could have a hundred thousand people die
of the flu
and you won't even hear about you won't
know that it's happening
but for kovid two deaths in a city
in two weeks is too many
the threat of covet must be precisely
zero or else we cannot return
to our lives that clearly is the
approach that our leaders are taking
with that in mind i would like to
suggest
a path forward if we cannot accept any
risk at all
then it's time that we do everything
that needs to be done
so th this right now i think this is big
news i am going to save
the world right now on this show you
weren't expecting that
i've only saved the world a few times in
the show this is this is another time
so here's my three-phase plan to achieve
our goal of zero covered risk
here it is phase one all unvaccinated
people
are loaded onto barges and set adrift in
the sea
now it's important that we respect their
rights which means that they
should be allowed to choose which ocean
they're exiled into
i i will say that you know it doesn't
really matter
that much so long as the ships of the
unclean remain a minimum of 55 miles off
shore
anything less and a strong breeze might
blow their virus fumes back to the
mainland
immediately killing thousands of people
we have no reason to think that such a
thing is possible but
there haven't been any studies done to
prove that it's not possible
i think and even if studies have proven
that it's not possible
where are the studies proving that those
studies are correct and if those studies
have been done
then where are the studies affirming
what the studies about the studies
have shown us phase two
all large gatherings are permanently
banned obviously
medium-sized gatherings also banned
small gatherings
also banned all types of gatherings are
nothing more than orgies of viral
transmission
there is no reason in the age of covid
why we should need to have any form of
physical interaction
with other human beings there is no need
for such frivolities anyway
especially when we have the internet
although speaking of the internet
virtual gatherings must be likewise
prohibited
we simply don't have enough data to
conclusively prove that the virus can't
infect you through zoom and besides
zoom carries other risks that are just
as severe
jeffrey tubin etc phase three
the government constructs artificial
cocoons a la the matrix
where we can be comfortably and
separately stored like packages of
ground beef
now here's the good news our cocoons
will be hermetically sealed of course
which means that we can squeeze
thousands of them into one facility
without worrying about viral
viral spread and i think it will it will
bring us great comfort to know that our
loved ones
have been stripped naked and locked
forever inside a dark robotic tomb
right near us you know of course inside
our individual pods all of our necessary
nutrients will be provided through our
government-issued umbilical cords for
entertainment and to stave off the
creeping approach of madness our brains
can be plugged into a computer system
giving us access to an entire virtual
world
where social distancing and masking will
still be observed of course
now i understand that these proposals
may seem drastic even
insane but remember that the goal now
is to avoid any and all risk no matter
how small
that is the goal if the measures i've
outlined here managed to save only
one life then they are worth trying
always remember the great lesson of
covid
that the only way to preserve our lives
is to stop living them and i think it's
finally time to get serious about that
we are all in this together well i mean
we'll be in separate pods but
together in our hearts and that's the
most important thing
now let's get to our five headlines
well the july and august heat is upon us
but that does not mean that you should
shave your beard that is no excuse
especially if you live
you know there's guys up north yankees
shaving your beard
i'm down here in the south it's 652
degrees
i've still got this coat on my face
because there are some things that are
more important than comfort but if you
do
uh have the beard especially during the
summer it's it's
couldn't be more important to keep it
tame and looking fresh no matter how
humid or dry your summer is turning out
to be
which is not why you need beard oil from
beard supply if you're one of these men
out there currently growing or
maintaining a beer chances are
you're in need of products to keep it
looking thick and healthy trust me you
don't want to show up to your
neighborhood barbecue
uh in the blistering heat without beard
oil you know your beard's gonna look
just mangy and
and disgusting um go visit
beardsupply.com
because for a limited time only you can
buy one beard oil product you can
and get another one for free so go visit
our friends over at beardsupply.com
today order yourself
two beard oils for the price of one you
wanna miss this deal so again that's
beardsupply.com to buy one beard oil
and get another one for free all right i
was uh
uh i was grateful by the way to go
i had a segment on uh with lara ingram
on fox news
last night i don't know if you got a
chance to watch it but if you didn't get
a chance you should go find that segment
somewhere and watch it because
it was really important uh i was brought
on to talk about
the issue of men crying which has been a
a theme on this show this week something
i've dealt with
repeatedly and it it's great that i'm
i'm always
brought if i'm if i'm doing a cable news
hit you know it's going to be the
important issues that's what they bring
me on for abuela men crying like that's
there's something really important going
on that's when they say we need to get
matt walsh here to talk about this
and uh so i did appreciate that and it
was a you know i thought it was a
worthwhile conversation
um just on that note i you know
you already i've talked about the the
tweet that i sent out where i said
mention cries unmanly and undignified
and that's what a lot of what has
sparked this reaction from people and it
hasn't stopped yet it has the outrage
mob they have not
usually like i've been through this many
times
and i've got the mob coming after me on
the internet
um and the reason i don't get upset
about it like so many people do well i'm
used to it it's also funny and who cares
what these people think
but i also know um that
the mob usually about 24 hours
like if it really bothers you what
they're saying which it shouldn't
then put your phone down for a day and
you go live your life while all these
people are obsessively
messaging you i hate you so much and you
don't usually it's 24 hours this has
been we're going on like three days and
they haven't let up
uh and so many of the responses are just
so funny i cannot recommend highly
enough
if you want to entertain yourself just
put something out on your own social
media channels about
how men should cry because the responses
are unintentionally hysterical
i wanna just share one more with you
okay this was uh someone last night
after my fox news hit uh this is a woman
and here's here's what she she said to
me she said
widdle baby can't handle your feelings
so you'll stuff them
as a therapist i like to encourage
people to express their emotions in a
healthy way
a man crying in public means he's very
sure of himself and comfortable with his
feelings
what does that say about you i love
everything about this
starting with little baby
little baby can't handle your feelings
as a therapist i disagree with that
really you're a therapist and that's how
you talk
to to people i almost respect that i
i've never been to therapy
a lot of people say that i i should
probably go um but i would really
respect
i guess a therapist where you sit down
and you start
telling them all your problems and your
life story
and they go oh widow baby are you upset
about that your your
childhood trauma little baby you want
some tissues
so i thought that was pretty great um
although
widdle baby can't handle the feeling so
you stuff them
are babies renowned for stifling their
emotions
is that is that what babies are all
about that hasn't been my experience
with babies
babies are are very bad at controlling
their emotions and cry constantly
my whole point is that men should not be
like babies
that is my radical suggestion okay
so if you're looking for a therapist uh
maybe i'll i'll
try to put you in touch with this woman
here so here's someone who really does
need therapy this is from the daily wire
a british reading out a british fashion
journalist
faced a storm of outrage thursday after
suggesting that children should be
watching
entry-level pornography a contributor to
gq
and the sunday time style magazine she
posted a twitter quote
someone needs to create oh there it is
someone needs to create porn for
children
hear me out young teens are already
watching porn but they're finding
hardcore aggressive videos that give a
terrible view of sex they need
entry-level porn
a soft core site where everyone asks for
consent
and no one gets choked etc
now she put that out there and then
deleted it within
i don't know within minutes maybe like
an hour top she deleted it really
quickly
um which which shows
this is the the bubble that these people
are living in
you know someone in the media a fashion
journalist
a living ice sub in london or something
and the the bubble she's in
that the bubble of degeneracy and
decadence that she's in
uh she she didn't know that people would
react negatively to that
and you know she didn't expect it
because she deleted it right away
you know if somebody says something
controversial
and then leaves it up there
it still might be grotesque and
outrageous and evil and insane like this
but at least you know that they knew it
was going to be controversial and
they were prepared for that they know
what they knew that what they were
getting into they leave it up there hey
it is what it is um they take it down
right away and that tells you that they
didn't think that this was going to be a
problem
she didn't think the circles that she
runs in
she thought that oh yeah entry-level
porn for kids what's the big deal
what oh you guys you guys have a problem
with that i had no idea
and later she kind of backtracked and
she was saying oh it's all about consent
i didn't mean to
insinuate this and that um she also
clarified this was supposed to make it
better
oh by children i mean just people under
18. so
you know 14 15 16. okay well that makes
it a lot better but if you look even at
her uh
what she was saying after the fact
trying to justify it after she deleted
it
there were plenty of people many of them
kind of like in her orbit you could tell
journalist media people defending her
and saying they think it sounds like a
good idea also
or at least they know what she was
getting at and you know it doesn't
offend them
of course it is offensive there are the
word offensive you know is
way overused people are offended by way
too many things there are things that
are
legitimately offensive proposing porn
for children
legitimately actually offensive if you
have a soul if you have any kind of
functioning moral compass at all
you're going to find that offensive and
outrageous and disgusting
but i should also note you know
her her proposal here as outrageous and
disgusting and evil
and deranged as it is
it's not that far from the view of many
people in fact
it's not that far
because you you probably know my opinion
on the subject of pornography very much
in the anti-camp
and um whenever i've talked about this
especially when you get into the risks
it posed to chill poses to children
i mean i've proposed in the fact in the
past
um i proposed banning pornography
outright which i still believe we should
do
of course most people very upset at that
notion don't take my pornography from me
it's all i have in my life is the
message you get from a lot of people
but even if you if you you back up a
little bit and you say okay
putting banning porn to the side what
about just
putting some measures in place to
protect children from it
some really basic measures not even
anything extreme
i'm in favor of the more extreme
measures but
what if we're not talking about that
what if we're talking about something
really some real basic stuff
for example uh requiring that
pornography sites like pornhub
verify ages before allowing people to
enter the site yeah there are ways
around that it's not
foolproof but it's definitely better
than nothing
and there are many different ways that
that that websites can verify ages there
are websites now that will actually do
this depending on
uh what kind of site it is you want to
do online gambling for example
you're gonna have to verify who you are
and verify your age
so there are ways to do it it's not that
onerous
it shouldn't be a big deal if you're an
adult
and you want to look at porn what's the
big deal you have to verify your age
but when i've suggested this or what
anyone suggests that people
lots of people are opposed to it
they would rather the pornography be
open for everyone
they would rather it be open and
available to everyone
knowing that millions of like
nine-year-olds are going to be
going to be exposed to the most depraved
and disgusting extreme pornography
imaginable
knowing that that's going to happen
because these measures are not put in
place
and there are millions of adults who are
okay with that
because the alternative is that their
own access might be
slightly impeded
if you even for a lot of adults if if
if you suggest even slightly impeding
their access to hardcore pornography
um that to them is is so offensive
that they would rather the alternative
of having nine-year-olds exposed to this
doing immense and immeasurable
psychological damage that will last for
their whole lives
so on one hand you've got this woman
saying let's intentionally
expose young children to pornography
um but it'll be you know it'll be sort
of
softer pornography so you've got that
and that's a horrible thing to say
but then you've got to in my experience
a lot of adults who
would say well let's not intentionally
expose them but at the same time
i don't really care if they are exposed
to hardcore porn
i don't want to do anything to stop that
from happening
those two viewpoints i would put about
on the same level
in terms of their depravity
and in terms of being utterly and
totally indefensible
any other industry i mean really
any other industry where a product or
service is being provided
that is not legal for children to
consume
in any other industry they are required
to do something to verify the age
you want to buy liquor in fact forget
about that
if if if pornography magazines even
still exist
and you went to a gas station
to buy one they'd have to verify your
age
you know if a nine-year-old went into a
gas station and bought a porn magazine
and the cashier just let him buy it
uh who would defend that and say well
it's really the parents fault
where are the parents yeah where are the
parents but at the same time how does
that justify what the cashier did
is it okay for the cashier to say well
your parents aren't here and uh
whatever sure i'll take your money
now in any other circumstance we expect
basic
measures to be put in place except with
porn sites
they are the one exception
that doesn't make any sense so
as horrifying as as this viewpoint is
it's really not far
from uh what many people believe and
you know and if you're in that camp
where you think we should do
absolutely nothing
from up from a you know a policy
perspective to insulate kids from this
then you're you're setting the stage for
people like this uh journalist here
just so you know all right let's go now
to um
uh for this from the sun it says
facebook ceo mark zuckerberg has
announced that
it's uh ray-ban smart glasses will be
the company's next product to launch
zuckerberg made the comment during
facebook's second quarter earnings call
facebook has uh planned to launch its
smart classes as its next product
he said looking ahead here the next
product release will be the launch of
our
first smart glasses from ray-ban in
partnership with
isilor laksatica whatever that is
uh the ceo didn't add much more than
other than that other than saying the
glasses will let the wearers do
some pretty neat things
what do we know about facebook smart
glasses so far facebook has big plans
for smart glasses but the first pair
won't be classified as an augmented
reality product
um and
as far as what it what as far as what
exactly they'll do
uh there's still not a lot no no but
you know these are elected so electronic
device you're gonna wear on your head
potentially giving facebook the ability
to record
everything you do and say
and there's a big privacy thing there um
but you know
here's what frustrates me
you ask almost anyone in america
whether or not they value their privacy
and whether their privacy rights are
important to them
all of them will say yes
one of the most important things in fact
based on our words
and the values and our values as we
present them
we value privacy more than anyone else
ever has in history we certainly talk
about it a lot more
and yet you know that these facebook
glasses are going to come out
and they'll sell like hot cakes
millions of people who otherwise would
say i really
i have a right to privacy i care so much
about my privacy
then facebook says oh here are some
glasses where i'm on your head will
record everything you do and say oh yes
please
this is always that that tension where
we we say we value our privacy and yet
all of us willingly sacrifice so much of
it every single day
as a matter of course uh and many of us
going much further than that
wearing facebook glasses i think would
be a pretty extreme
way to sacrifice your own privacy okay i
want to play this i can't forget to play
this a restaurant owner in california
is uh switching things up a little bit
he is allowing only the unvaccinated
to eat at his establishment so he's
requiring proof of being
unvaccinated i don't know how exactly
you could prove that but
uh clearly he's trying to just make a
point here he's making a statement
about um about the idea of vaccine
passports
chris cuomo had him on his show to
yell at him and i think it probably
didn't go exactly how chris cuomo
planned let's take a look at that the
whole reason this is happening is
because people
won't protect themselves tony i mean
what are you thinking
then why did you leave your house when
when you had coveted i mean you had it
and you left your house i mean it's been
documented first of all it has been
documented
it's been documented i quarantined
i went out my wife got accosted by
somebody
and i i know you don't know so i'm
trying to help you the science is clear
tony
trying to help me i don't want you to
get sick the way i was science is clear
oh you care about me all of a sudden huh
enough to have you on the show because i
don't like people uh making bad
decisions for themselves and their
family
i was hoping it was a little bit of a
stunt oh you have the freedom not to
take the vaccine i just don't know why
you think it's a good move
maybe maybe we should ask your brother
about protecting people right hey look
that's his job and if he doesn't do it
well people will
hopefully a whole new can of worms but
don't look tony look i don't know if you
know me too well i'm not trying to
myself
about you yeah good i appreciate that
too because i know you talk a lot so
so my my stance here is a pro freedom
stand only it's not political you're
never gonna
if you come down here you're not gonna
see a trump flag flying over the roof
okay you're not gonna see campaign signs
you're not to see
campaign slogans or political slogans
ever okay you're only going to see
pro freedom messages and that's it
um and you're not going to drag me down
the hole talking about the science
this is not about whether i'm
pro-vaccine or not i'm throw
freedom anti-tyranny okay and uh you
know
maybe the conversation should really be
between me and your brother
that that's what i'm thinking really
that whole clip
the the only thing i wanted to get out
of that is
where he said i quarantined i went out
i quarantined i went out
but then you're not quarantining that's
going out it's like the definition of
quarantine is not leaving
it's not going out so of course cuomo
gets called out there which uh which is
which is good to see and what the
restaurant owner
i think what was his name tony um
what he's saying there is of course
exactly exactly right and this
is the distinction that many people on
the
pro vaccine passport side of things many
of the coveted cultists
pretend not to understand
okay if if you're against vaccine
passports if you're against
don lemon's idea of if you don't
vaccinate you're not allowed to
eat at any restaurants or fly on
airplanes and do anything
if you're against those kinds of
measures then uh that that does it that
doesn't necessarily mean
i mean you could you could also be
against the covet vaccine
but that's an additional viewpoint that
you have that you happen to have
that's not necessary
not necessary to have any particular
view on vaccines one one way or another
to be in favor of people having the
right and the liberty to go and
and live their life and participate in
society
i really hate the the whole way that we
approach vaccines
i've always hated and this goes this is
not new i mean this goes back
before covid was ever before anyone
before covet 19 was a thing
ford existed um
we had already done this with vaccines
we had turned vaccines into an
ideological political thing
and that's another important point
because the way that we talk about the
covid
vaccine debate it's like a lot of people
think that
this is a this is a new that for
vaccines to be an ideological
battlefield that's a new development
it's not
way before this it was
well your pro-vaccine or your
anti-vaccine
and the two sides you really don't like
each other and the people who
would identify themselves on either side
of that spectrum if they ever talk to
you and they didn't know where you
landed they they would kind of like
demand that you take one side or the
other
it never made any sense to me wait
anti-vaccine pro what do you mean it it
depends on the vaccine it depends on the
situation it depends on
who's getting the vaccine why they're
getting it
am i in favor of every vaccine that's
ever been developed
probably not am i in favor of everyone
in the world getting every vaccine
no i probably not it really depends
it depends this is a this is a
medical treatment medical
um decision at least
and so it's it's going to be kind of a
case-by-case basis
that's been my take on vaccines i've
never been able to
plant my flag as pro or anti when it
comes to vaccines
or frankly to care that much whether you
do or don't get them
whatever the vaccine is all right we've
also got this
speaking of really important stories um
and we've talked about men crying here's
another important story this one fox 5
and dc
they're tracking down a really important
story about
i don't know if you knew this this is a
big crisis level situation
um dog groomers apparently are
unlicensed
and fox5 they're on top of this let's
watch
hey guys it's fox 5 reporter sierra fox
right now i am here with
abby and lucy they're outside of happy
grooming just got
beautiful and they feel good their tails
are wagging
today my story is about how pet groomers
don't have to have
any sort of licensing or regulations to
some pet owners after hearing that
that's concerning so i'll have more
details for you about this
coming up at four five and six
bye guys that is that is that is a huge
concern
i i i didn't i didn't realize that i
thought that
uh you would have to you know go to
school for six years
take three years of additional training
go through bi-annual testing
spend uh you know at least five or six
thousand dollars a year
in licensing fees in order to cut a
dog's hair
that's what i thought and and i found a
certain amount of of
of comfort in in that belief thinking
that there weren't any unlicensed
unregulated people out there just
willy-nilly cutting the hairs of dogs
but fox5 they point out no not only are
there some unlicensed
dog haircutters but ev they all are
we got to get the government involved in
this that is
obviously the case um all right this is
something
here's another thing really serious
we're doing all this serious stuff today
it is a friday after all
you guys know that i'm a i'm a huge fan
of of lizzo i'm very protective of her
and so i was naturally pretty upset
when some vicious rumors about lizzo
started circulating and
apparently some people online were and
this is not funny at all
they were claiming that lizzo
uh was stage dived
at a concert and killed someone um
just flattened them by like a pancake
that was the claim
it's terrible stuff it's not funny it's
completely untrue
she didn't kill anyone they survived
only a few broken bones
uh so let's be clear about that but
here's here's lizzo addressing this this
rumor so i've seen a lot of annoying
things about me on the internet
but the thing that bothers me the most
is this rumor
that i stage dived at a concert and
killed somebody
like that rumor it's a fly first of all
i've never stage dived in my life and
how like kill somebody y'all really
gonna put that on my mother's
name like i know i'm big but
i'm not that [ __ ] big like look
uh there it is it's
it is repugnant that these rumors would
spread
and i want to be clear that there were
no earthquakes caused either so so
please do
don't start joking about that this was
not similar in severity to an asteroid
strike
you know okay um i'm i'm really just
disgusted by
by those kinds of comments from from the
internet
very disappointed in the internet today
frankly
all right um one other thing let's see
what else do we got before we get to
uh read the youtube comments
okay here's one other this is um angie
jones who's a
international keynote speaker with a
pretty large following
she uh tweeted this and this kind of
went viral this
this claim that she made she says this
weekend i went on a girls trip
ten black women flying first class
people literally could not process how
it was possible
staff tried to send us to regular lines
passengers made snide remarks
one guy even yelled are they a higher
class of people than i
am stay mad
and of course there are a lot of
comments a lot of uh yas queens and that
sort of thing in the comments
uh can we just be totally clear that
this didn't happen that that did not
happen
it's possible that that she happened to
be on a plane flying first class
with the one guy in the country who's
never heard of first class
and so he sees that and says what first
class what are they a higher class of
of individuals it's it's possible that
that happened but but really unlikely
and all the rest of it is her simply
sort of assuming
that everyone is mad that they're in
first class if they were staring at all
it's just because it's unusual to have a
group of 10 people all together flying
first class
uh it had to be a pretty big plane to
even fit that many people
uh a group that that size in first class
but so that's possible
but the rest of it is her assuming that
everyone cares
when in reality nobody cares no one
cares that you're flying first class
you know it's a big deal for you you're
impressed with yourself for flying first
class that's great
i've flown first class a couple of times
i was impressed with myself too
but no one else cares
this is this is something for taking the
racial element out of it
this is something for narcissists to to
it's a really important lesson for them
to
to learn uh for for all of us to learn
and there's there's actually a freedom
in this when you when you realize it and
you learn it
and it really takes hold in your in your
mind
no one really cares what you're doing
okay when you walk around in the world
in public
if you have this idea that everyone is
staring at you
judging you for better or worse everyone
cares
that's your narcissism flaring up that
is the definition of a narcissist
you're imagining that when you walk into
an environment like you get on a plane
you're the main character in that story
and everyone is revolving around you
waiting for you to show up and even if
you're imagining that everyone hates you
or they're judging you that is still
narcissism
and it's delusional because no they
don't hate you they're not judging you
they aren't thinking about you they
don't care
everyone on that plane they're going
somewhere they're coming from somewhere
else they've got
they've got a million things going on in
their own lives
they've got other annoyances they're
annoyed they have to wear the mask
they're annoyed that they're on the
plane
you know they've got maybe their kids
with them they've got
marital problems they're thinking about
problems at their job
issues with their family that's where
their head is
if they thought about you at all it was
for like 10
seconds they might have noticed you for
10 seconds and had and had a thought
about you for 10 seconds positive or
negative
and then they moved on with their lives
and they will never think about you
again
now when you really realize that it
might start to cure your narcissism a
little bit
uh but then it's also freeing
because not only can it rid you of your
narcissism it can also rid you of a lot
of the anxiety people have when they're
out in public
feeling like they're judged all the time
it's they're not judging you they don't
care
even if you're in public and and
something really embarrassing happens to
you
even then people point and laugh and
then they're gonna move on with their
lives they'll probably never think about
it again
i think it depends on how embarrassing
it is you know it's possible if it's
something really bad
then you know i don't know if you pee
your pants in public or something
probably people will remember that
forever and they'll be telling stories
about it forever so that i would
recommend against that but
for the most part no one's thinking
about it no one cares all right let's
move now to reading youtube comments
uh cool papa j magic says
it really it really stinks that the
greatest minds of our generation
are forced to debate garbage like
socialism masks slash whether or not
gender even exists etc you do a great
show anyway matt thanks
uh i don't know if i qualify as one of
the greatest minds of our generation
but i appreciate it and i i do agree
that this is it's unfortunate that we're
stuck debating these really elementary
elementary things it works out for me
i've been very open and honest about
this
that if our society was not going
completely insane
i wouldn't have a job because all i
really do
is is point out the obvious
and there's a need for that now there's
a place for that for people to point out
the most obvious things in the world
that's all i do that's my whole gig if
most people were basically sane
then we wouldn't need anyone to point
out the obvious we we wouldn't need a
captain obvious show which is what this
is
um but we do so that's that's that's
that's my gig
if if we get to a point where people
snap out of it
and we live in a basically sane society
that'll be great the one downside for me
is that i gotta find a new job i'll take
that trade
by the way um
another comment says wow matt i really
feel for you my wife is very artistic
and loves to decorate but for the most
part we have the same taste and we don't
like
those inspirational quotes but i must
say i'm surprised that you so hate it
but haven't done your manly duty and set
your wife on the straight and narrow
path
do you have something to confess does
she carry more sway in the house than
you do
are you saying she doesn't listen to her
sweet dead daddy walsh's desires and
home decorating
um my wife does not call me sweet daddy
watch let me be very clear about that
that would be even a bridge too far no
it's somehow much less creepy for a
whole bunch of strangers
to call me that no i entirely defer
to my wife on all decor and decorating
things um i i don't care about that
i might well i might formulate an
opinion about some of it
i don't care enough about that opinion
to have an argument about it
and i also realize and this is a it's a
big part i think of of making a marriage
work right is
is realizing what your strengths and
weaknesses are
you got to know that because then you
know where
to defer to the other and and how to
lean on them
when it comes to any kind of decorating
related thing
i have no idea
you know you you you put me in an empty
room
give me furniture give me decorations
and they can be the highest quality
furniture and decorations
on earth i would have no clue how to
assemble it
in a way that's visually appealing
my wife uh is very talented at that so
let's see um matt your words are so
inspirational and powerful then why
hasn't your wife plastered them all over
your bathroom
now that is a good point see there there
is a decorating
idea that i that i do find especially
appealing
should be quotes from me all over that
that wouldn't be narcissistic at all
um and uh
half irish says i'd like to hear what
you expect would happen to those 300 000
unwanted babies if they were born
or the 300 000 uh babies that planned
parenthood kills every year and those
are only the babies that planned
parenthood kills
um they're just one of the you know
abortion
conglomerates the one one one one set of
abortion clinics and planned parenthood
uh but you know you've got 800 900 000 a
million babies that are killed every
year all told
so but the 300 000 what happens to them
if they're not killed in abortion
um well the answer is i don't know
exactly
hopefully they find a loving home i
i i think many of these mothers
who make the decision to get an abortion
if they had not made that decision
and i know this because you could talk
to mothers who
considered getting an abortion and were
going to but decided not to
talk to them and see see how they feel
about it a year later two years later
five years later
almost none of them will tell you that
they wish they had gone through with the
abortion
in fact i have never personally heard
that from any woman
and i've talked to plenty who who had
considered abortion
so what what does that mean it means
that of those 300 000 a great many of
them
will find loving homes in their own home
in their in with their biological at
least their biological mother hopefully
their biological father too
of the ones that do not hopefully a
great number of them
um are adopted
and although it is it is difficult it's
tragically difficult
for a seven or eight or nine-year-old
child to find a home
willing to adopt him and that's a
terrible and tragic thing
the good thing is it is not difficult at
all to find homes that will adopt babies
there's a very long waiting list of
loving and capable families that want
desperately to adopt babies
and so you know i think that's the
answer for the rest of those of those
quote unquote unwanted children they
would end up getting adopted
and you know what even if the worst
happens
these children end up on the street
they end up in abusive homes horrible
situations that you wouldn't wish on any
kid
am i going to say that i think it'd be
better if they were dead
is that what you're saying i guess it is
what about children that are in abusive
situations or horrible situations right
now should we just go kill them
what about adults that are on the street
homeless living miserable lives of
despair and emptiness and suffering
with no hope in sight should we just go
kill them better to be dead
because that's what you're saying if
you're
unwanted better off dead
now i i absolutely reject that i think
it is better to live
definitely and certainly
it is not up to us to decide if someone
else's life
is worth living as we have discussed the
cdc
is now recommending that vaccinated
individuals wear masks
indoors and outdoors in fact uh and uh
you know they haven't quite gotten to
the point of suggesting that we all go
into the matrix pods but now that i've
put that idea out into the universe
maybe it'll actually happen
i apologize for that um but this is all
about
authoritarianism and uh that's why ben
shapiro's book
his new book the authoritarian moment
could not be more timely or necessary
when you pick up ben's book you'll learn
how to stand strong against the
authoritarians who are trying to
make you submit to their cause the
authoritarian moment is now available
at amazon barnes noble or any other
major booksellers so go pick
up a copy today and you know it seems
like we can't
go a day without fresh terrible news
about how our authoritarian overlords
are attempting to
squeeze americans of every last bit of
our freedom which is why i think it's
important
that i provide some good news for you
and here it is if you've ever thought
it'd be cool to travel
to the daily wires studios on the daily
wires dime
and uh hang out in nashville smoke a
cigar with the hosts of
daily wire backstage if you've ever
thought about that now is the time that
you can do it because if you're not a
member yet this is your chance head to
dailywire.com
subscribe and use code backstage to get
25 off your new membership
and be automatically entered to win two
tickets to lounge with the daily wire
legends backstage and that's not all
you get to take home cop take home some
signed copies of
michael and ben's newest books but not
mine if
none of that entices you just remember
you unlike most people will get to meet
me
as well so head to dailywire.com
subscribe with code backstage to get 25
off your membership and a chance to win
the ultimate backstage experience now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today for our daily cancellation we
finally have an opportunity to cancel
msnbc host chris hayes he has of course
said many things at a warrant
cancellation but
his stupidity is often overshadowed by
many of his fellow cable news hosts and
media personalities
um hayes rarely gets the idiot credit
that he deserves and today i aim to
change that
yesterday hayes took to twitter to
defend the idea that vaccinated people
should wear masks
um using an analogy that many of his
followers seem to think was quite
brilliant
he tweeted quote you're telling me i
have to buckle my seatbelt even though i
have airbags
either the airbags work or the seat belt
works but it can't be both
this by the way had over 60 000 likes
nearly 10 000 retweets last i checked
like i said his followers found it to be
a deeply compelling argument
the only problem with the argument is
that it is profoundly stupid
as is so often the case with the covid
cult the arguments they make
actually undermine the very point they
are trying to defend
in fact the analogy he makes here so
brilliantly proves the opposite of the
point that he's trying to prove
that i wish i had thought of it myself
so let's
let's break it down shall we obviously
hayes is drawing a comparison between
vehicle safety measures
and coveted prevention measures in this
analogy the airbags are the vaccine and
the seatbelts are the masks i'm actually
going to go to
do him a favor and flip that around to
make it slightly more intelligible and
slightly less dumb
seat belts are after all the most
important and effective line of defense
in a car accident
not the airbags i'm assuming that chris
hayes would say that vaccines are the
most important and effective line of
defense against the virus
if he's saying that the vaccine is but
an additional measure to add on to
masking
rather than the other way around then we
have a whole new list of issues to deal
with but again i'm going to be generous
and make his argument better
so that i can have more fun debunking it
now
according to the cdc and the insurance
institute for
highway safety seat belts alone
reduce your risk of death in a car
accident by about 45 to 50
airbags alone reduce your risk by 34
together by the combination reduces risk
of death by around
60 percent but here's the point
seat belts only reduce your risk of
death by 45 to 50 percent
it is their relative ineffectiveness
which necessitates that another measure
be put in place as well
even though that measure is also
relatively ineffective
together they're a whole lot better than
nothing but if you get into a head-on
collision especially on the highway
there's still a
very good chance that you will die or at
least be seriously injured
that's how relatively ineffective these
measures are
let's bring this over to the vaccines
remember
the airbag is needed because the
seatbelt by itself
is relatively ineffective that's the
whole reason
we have the airbag if seat belts reduce
your risk of death by saying 99
and your risk of serious injury by a
margin nearly as large
then there wouldn't be any need for
airbags in fact
you really shouldn't have airbags in
that case because the airbags themselves
can cause injuries like broken noses and
concussions
if the seat belts were 99 effective at
preventing death the airbag would likely
do more harm than good
so how does this relate to vaccines
is chris hayes saying that the vaccines
are relatively ineffective
is this an anti-vaxx argument from chris
hayes is this vaccine misinformation
perhaps we should report him to twitter
get him de-platform before his anti-vax
extremism
gets people killed i mean that must be
what he's saying
if he's relating them to seat belts or
airbags after all in 2019
53 of vehicle occupants who died in car
wrecks were wearing seat belts
does hayes think that over half of the
people who die from covid are vaccinated
the point matters because the necessity
for additional
safety measures depends entirely on the
effectiveness of the primary measure
if you're saying that the other measures
are needed you're making a statement
about the
ineffectiveness of the primary measure
but if you acknowledge that the primary
measure is extremely effective at
preventing very bad outcomes
and yet you still advocate for
additional measures anyway and for those
measures to be mandated and forced by
the government
then you've opened up a door that cannot
be closed
you have erased a line and won't be able
to justify redrawing it anywhere else
you've advocated for something without
any limiting principle to contain it
if the vaccines are highly effective at
preventing death and hospitalization if
the protection they afford you is
way into the 90th percentile 97 98 99 or
more
and yet you still want more to be done
then why just that why a vaccine
and a mask why not a vaccine in two
masks or three masks why not mandate
full hazmat suits for everybody when
they leave their house
now we may not have enough hazmat suits
to go around right now but i'm sure we
could solve that problem
so seriously why not the hazmat suit if
we could manage to produce enough
if we could why not mandate them
in addition to vaccines they would
reduce the spread considerably more than
just a mask
it's not harming anyone to wear them it
isn't going to hurt you physically
it's a small sacrifice it's just a thing
you're wearing that's all
so why not i want an answer to that
question
but you don't want to give an answer to
that question because the answer is
something like
okay take it easy that's ridiculous it's
way overboard
yeah you're right and it's also way
overboard to expect
immune people with an infinitesimal risk
of serious infection to walk around
all day every day in face masks
that is also ridiculous and overboard
if your answer is well just do it anyway
better safe than sorry
then we're back to having no way to
explain why we should just go with full
hazmat suits
this is what's lost in our discussion of
covet it's what's been lost from the
beginning
that is any notion of proportionality
and probability and perspective
the three p's have been thrown out the
window
in fact let's um let's go back to the
car for a moment
1.3 million people die in car accidents
every year worldwide
in the u.s alone an additional four and
a half million people are injured often
severely
around 600 children under the age of 13
are killed in car crashes
every year in this country and that is
significantly more than diet of covet in
the in that age group
seat belts and airbags together only
reduce the risk of death by 60
so why hasn't chris hayes called for
additional mandated safety measures
there
why don't we require everyone in the car
to wear racing helmets for example
again putting the logistical issues to
the side because they can be solved i
mean we could require all car
manufacturers to provide racing helmets
with their cars like they provide spare
tires
does that seem onerous sure but
literally millions of people are dying
hundreds of very young children if we're
supposed to believe that it's not safe
for an immune person to walk through a
grocery store without a mask
then how can we possibly consider it
safe to drive to that grocery store with
only a seat belt and an airbag to
protect you
at this point is the immune person more
likely to die
in the car on the way to the store or
from a virus he picks up while he's
inside it
does anybody want to claim it's the
latter do you really think that's how
the probabilities shake out here
in fact why are we allowing people to
drive at all
you're speeding down the road at 60 or
70 miles an hour or more in a large
metal bucket
one wrong move one second of distraction
by you or someone else in another car
can end your life and the lives of all
your passengers your entire family can
die in an
instant and it's happened many times
it's a dangerous activity an activity
that carries with it a not insignificant
risk of death or bodily harm
it's hard to see how it's safer
to do that than it is for an immune
person
to walk through a crowd without a mask
and yet we do it every day without
thinking about it
without worrying about it we know a
million people will die
every year from this we know that we
might die from this
we know that we put our children in the
car they might die
every time you strap your child into the
car you know he might die
from this activity that you were doing
right now and you might kill him
you might be the one to do it
accidentally but we do it anyway
we don't even hesitate we do it much of
the time when it's not remotely
necessary
going places we don't strictly speaking
need to go nobody ever stops and weighs
the risk of driving against the
necessity of going to the place they're
about to go to nobody does that
they just get in and drive and a million
of them die
every year year after year after year
after year
yes coveted is not the same as a car
accident but then again i'm not the one
who made this analogy
while we're on the subject though since
chris hayes brought it up
it does demonstrate how we calculate our
risk from covid in a way that is
completely different
from how we calculate it anywhere else
in life even when faced with
greater threats there are many things
out there
that are more likely to kill us and yet
we worry less about them
and do almost nothing to prevent them
that makes no sense it is irrational it
is fear-based
and fear-based decisions are almost
always irrational
as chris hayes has proved though he
didn't mean to
and for that he is canceled and we'll
end it there
for the day and the week have a great
weekend everybody talk to you next week
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pavel vadasky the
show is edited by sasha tulmachov
our audios mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
john bickley here editor-in-chief of
daily wire wake up every morning with
our new show
morning wire on today's episode
president biden addresses immigration
and crime
countries around the world loosen their
travel restrictions and democrats push
for student loan
forgiveness join us and get the facts
first on the news you need to know with
our show
morning wire